we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail with an interesting little
prediction about what will happen to
this show if Donald Trump loses I've
talked before about listen there's no
question I think Trump is terrible for
the country in the world but our show is
bigger today thanks to Trump being the
president than Hillary had Hillary been
the president I don't believe
independent media this is not just my
show would have seen nearly the growth
that we've seen since November of 2016
that's a reality I still want the guy to
lose because he's terrible for the
country here's a different type of
prediction about what Trump's loss would
lead to for the David Pakman show
hello David this is tea from California
and I just want to tell you what exactly
it's gonna happen the house will vote to
impeach the Senate will not be able to
get a conviction so the president will
not get thrown out because of
impeachment we're gonna have to put him
out then if we're lucky enough to vote
him out I don't think you're gonna have
your radio show anymore because as soon
as they vote him out I think he might
get hired by Fox News well to replace
Shepard Smith that's the end of the
David Pakman show yeah I don't see that
happening
at any time I would be I can't even
imagine
I was going to say I would be last on
the list to replace Shep Smith on fox
news I don't even think I'm on any list
that exists for doing anything on fox
news particularly remember the last time
I was supposed to be on Fox News
I took a lift over to the the satellite
studio nobody was there I called and was
told oh nobody told you that Fox
canceled this several hours ago no
nobody told me and that's the last I
ever heard from them and they've not
invited me back on since and it was
quite quite a fiasco
so in any case no I don't I don't see
any plan for that I don't see any path
to that whatsoever we have a great bonus
show planned for you today if you're
satisfied with
what you've seen from us today so far
then forget about the bonus show if you
want more today instead of waiting until
tomorrow become a member or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
join pakman.com because on the bonus
show we will talking about Barack Obama
said something very interesting Barack
Obama said Democrats don't always need
to be politically woke and tweeting
stuff on Twitter is not really activism
very interesting comments we will also
talk about a girlfriend charged in the
death of a boston college student after
telling him hundreds of time to kill
himself according to prosecutors a very
disturbing but legally interesting case
and we will talk about the California
fires warnings for Los Angeles are
progressing north a former TV director
of the David Pakman show Natan Pakman
having to work from home as a result of
these fires he lives in LA can you
imagine all of those stories and more on
the bonus show I'll see you then